اكد الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
كوتيتير الشاهقته الكامله في مبعوثه الخاص
ورئيس البعثه الامميه في السودان
فولكاربرتز واضاف جوتيريش في تصريح عقب
جلسه مغلقه بشان السودان انا الامر متروك
لمجلس الامن ليقرر في شان البعثه وعلمت
الجزيره من مصدر دبلوماسيا للامين العام
اقترح اعتمادا تمديد تقني للبعثه لمده سته
اشهر من اجل تقييم دورها وان بريطانيا تعد
مشروع قرار بهذا الصدد وتنتهي ولايه بعثه
الامم المتحده في السودان المعروفه
في الثالث من يونيو الجري
شن السودان
فيما يتعلق بالوضع في السودان هناك مجالات
للمسؤوليه مجلس الامن وهناك مجالات
لمسؤوليه الامين العام وفي مجال المسؤوليه
اكدت للمجلس من جديد ثقه الكامله
كممثل خاص للامين العام والامر متروك
لمجلس الامن ليقرر ما اذا كان يؤيد
استمرار البعثه لفتره اخرى او ما اذا كان
سيقرر ان الوقت قد حان لانهائها